mic silver of NFL Media Group on nfl.com
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Mike how are you I'm good you were in
the room there last night in the draft
room or around the Arizona Cardinals huh
what in what happened with Josh Rosen
last night to the best of your ability
and knowledge here well I was not in the
draft room or I honestly I might have
spoken up just it was starting to get
awkward
no I'm kidding but right yeah you know I
had a long talk with Steve came the
night before the draft and had a a
general sense of you know what his loose
plan was not specifically that he was
taking Cuyler Murray but that yeah this
was a giant pick for him his his job is
obviously you know in a more tenuous
position that it has been and he
correctly said if we ever have this pick
again I won't be the one making it so
you got to get it right and he you know
he he felt like they needed to be bold
but you know I would assume that when
you're trying to make the move to take a
new quarterback after you traded up to
get one in the first round the year
before and Josh Rosen that you would
have a a pre-emptive plan in terms of
moving Josh Rosen but Steve kinda
attitude was you know what I've been in
situations before where we ran out of
quarterbacks most infamously the Ryan
Lindley started playoff game four years
ago and you know you can never have
enough quarterbacks that's an
interesting theory but you know the we
can get into it the potential for
awkwardness and strain if these are the
two quarterbacks you have on your roster
going of the season is very very high
and you know people around the league
were surprised all the way up until the
draft that the Cardinals were not more
actively trying to plot a rose and trade
and and the strategy of well we'll just
draft Murray and wait for someone to
come to us has not worked as far you saw
the the Giants of Washington go get
their guys drew Locke is still on the
board Miami I know has some interest and
and the Chargers and possibly someone
else
but you know the Cardinals are saying we
think he's worth a draft pick in the top
half of the first round right now it's
looking like a fire sale or keep him and
have a very awkward dynamic well I mean
he is worth a draft choice of notes I
think I don't know about top half of the
first round but it's possible the
problem is though is you have to have
the leverage to create that draft choice
to come your way and they there's no
chance they could do that now or even if
they hold on to him unless a sort of
Minnesota Vikings of the summer two
years ago type sinkhole opens up where
someone like Bridgewater goes down and
they gotta get somebody on the spot as
we got a Viking fan who's here in the
Marriott in Nashville is nodding his
head and giving me a thumbs up on this
analogy I mean like this but what are
the odds of something like that
happening and right I mean the the idea
that you're going to have two young
quarterbacks in the same room including
one who's been supplanted in the most
Awkward and potentially embarrassing way
that's one way that could be looking you
could look at it Mike and also why
saddle your new first-time head coach
with having to at all navigate those
waters right I mean look let's break it
down even further I am a big Josh Rosen
fan you know he's very very smart he's
already from what I've been told you
know active Kingsbury's offense very
very well he's gone against some people
stereotype of him and he put it down and
blocked out the noise and by all
accounts been a leader and a good
teammate and I think he sincerely wanted
to stay in Arizona that you know he got
knocked around a lot last year behind a
substandard offensive line they had a
miserable season but it's not like he
you know it's not like either side given
up on the other based on what happened
last year so you've got him who's
picking up this offense Kyler Murray is
a guy who like any young quarterback who
comes from you know college is gonna
have to figure it out on the fly so I
would say Rosen has a huge edge in that
department and then personality-wise you
know Rosen may not be your you know he
may not be Peyton Manning sucked the air
out of the room but he's got more juice
to him in terms of you know extroverted
personality than by all accounts Kyler
Murray does who is much more of a you
know reactive kind of passive
personality obviously a dynamic player
and I and you know has a chance to be to
be great but if you put those you know
you put all that together and then you
know throw in the fact that Josh Rosen
is understandably upset and look not
just because I do think he rationally
understands the business part of it but
the handling of it again has not been
great you had you know the team you had
Kings burying time and the Cardinals you
know social media site coming out early
saying Josh is the guy hahaha then it
was the worst kept secret in football
that they were locked in armory and if
you can't keep that secret then you
might as well you know try to start
shopping them and and as you said using
what leverage you have that will
eventually disappear and I tried to lay
out in my story some reasons that they
had for trying to conceal their
intentions they did a bad job of it but
you know the reasons would be other than
of course helping us from a programming
perspective which rich as you know have
come aboard
NFL media my practice of sipping picks
has gone away so it's gone you know I'm
it's gone you had to find a new branding
Mike I don't want it guys crushed it
last night and those drinks from a DJ
you know in the big chair and I'm sure
you're very tired but yeah other than
that you know the reasons for keeping
people in suspense I guess were you know
you're trying to have some leverage when
you talk to Kyler's Murray's agent about
the baseball language in the contract
and my understanding is that they came
to a philosophical agreement on that
though they did not
signing a contract which they would have
been allowed to do and literally get the
language done so in theory they're okay
they're you know and then you know the
other reason would be you're hoping
somebody's gonna just blow your you know
blow doors an incredible offer that you
are willing to trade out of they loved
Nick both and Quinta Williams so
certainly they would have trade down to
two or three more readily than they
would have traded below that but you
know you and I both knew going into the
draft the chances of that we're also
very remote so I I I'm a little
mystified as to why you didn't just
acknowledge what the rest of the world
knew and say yeah we're really looking
hard to Kyler's Murray he's very likely
the guy and we're gonna explore you know
trade options and see what we can get
for Josh Rosen nothing personal
last one for you Mike silver in a minute
I have left with you your your bags are
packed you are literally on Rosen watch
do you think you hop a flight today to
go to Rosen's new digs what do you think
that is a great question and I'm you
know it's a it's a metric between me our
great travel agent at oedipal Network
people in charge of my schedule and
Steve time possibly Chris Greer to let
go and and other interested parties I
would imagine so in all likelihood once
I get on the tarmac heading somewhere on
an airplane is when the deal will go
down and it will probably be Miami
because that's as far away from Arizona
let me answer it real quickly I think if
they're serious that they're willing to
keep them they're not going to get a
good enough offer today so you might as
well just you know hold firm and keep
them I suspect they're gonna come around
that it's gonna be a fire sale and it'll
probably happen today or tomorrow all
right you the man Mike thanks to the
call appreciate it thank you Richard
travel well that's Mike silver with the
latest right there on now Josh Rosen for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download
Rich Eisen show app